okay first time nominee dr death i did
those junket interviews with you was
obsessed then it's so awesome to see it
nominated how you feeling it is awesome
to to be nominated it's true i i mean it
was
as we talked about back then it was a
very intense experience
both with the material that we were
working on and the fact that we were the
first show back in new york post covid
so there was just a lot in the air and
to get through that and and be proud of
the work and then to have it recognized
is kind of the
best the goal thing yeah you and
christian both nominated have you talked
about how you should go and the show
yeah how will you feel if you win do you
have a speech ready
i don't
um
which as honestly as i was on the way
over i was like that might have been an
oversight
that might have been like two canadian
modest of like i'm not going to win this
thing i don't have to prepare anything
so i
yeah okay
and anxiety for the next two hours
thanks you thank your wife
as long as i get the wife i feel like
everything else i can paper over it by
the way love the brooch what are we
wearing thank you we're wearing a little
uh bulgari gucci combination here today
also a casual sunday for me i mean yeah
um i know baby girl big milestone turn
in one soon two
turn two how are you celebrating what
what is she talking she's saying mom and
dad oh yeah yeah oh yeah no she's
talking about we when we were leaving to
come down here today she was like i come
work
i come i come too i come too
do we have a future actress
actress is gonna be too small for her i
don't know she's gonna rule the world
okay we gotta talk about a milestone of
yours i wanna make sure i have this
right you too you and jody are doing a j
crew campaign but 20 years ago you were
in a j crew campaign with the dawson's
creek people yes
was that surreal
when they first brought it up i wanted
because
when they first brought it up it was for
her
and then they were like you know and
they're looking for a husband in the
thing and then would you shoot i was
like you you know i go back a little
ways like somewhere there's a photograph
of me with a bad bowl cut and a dog
was the bowl cut that bad it had its
look
obviously i didn't mind it would you do
it again
um
no i probably would not do it again
everything that's old comes back in
style again yeah except for me i'm old
now
it looks a little bit different on a 43
year old man than it does on a 19 year
old man
that's that's you know what that is
perspective yeah um god ask you about
fatal attraction you and lizzy cat like
this is exciting and that's a steamy
movie what can we expect from the show
i mean it goes right there there's
nothing it doesn't pull any punches so
what you can expect is a
deeper dive into the story that you
already know from the film that balances
out the perspective between the man and
the woman
right
that movie is amazing but if you watch
it today the gender politics don't
really hold up very well
and so
this gives an opportunity to balance
that out and get into her story and the
psychology of where she was coming from
rather than you know just being crazy
being so black and white and yeah and
not crazy crazy um do you and jody you
guys are so busy do you run lines
together do you rehearse together
yeah we i mean not all the time every
day but yeah we do that i mean we're two
actors this is what we love to do
yeah i'll let you go but we also got to
ask mighty ducks has had such a
resurgence could we ever see you reprise
charlie
i don't think so um
i mean i i know that they're like
it's a
it's a work balance issue so
um but i don't think so no
never say never but but not for the next
season
all right i will keep praying i'll let
you go enjoy tonight go work on that
speech my friends yeah i know i need to
like
go on imdb and start writing things down
[Music]